CSI crime scene investigation was a
cultural phenomenon that redefined the
TV procedural for the 21st century the
show's first spin-off CSI Miami
resuscitated star David Caruso's career
and was still pulling in viewers when it
was abruptly canceled after 10 seasons
in 2012 and there's only one way to find
out what went wrong we're gonna do I I'm
gonna get to the truth
ratings massacre in the 2011 / 12 TV
season which would prove to be its last
year on the air CSI Miami ranked number
27 out of all shows on broadcast TV now
that's pretty good but not so good for
CBS the most-watched Network it also
represented a steady decline for the
once mighty crime drama in its debut
season CSI Miami ranked number 11 and
then spent four years in the top ten
before starting an annual rating slide
also not helping was it's Sunday night
timeslot despite a leading from The Good
Wife CSI Miami got killed in the ratings
by NBC's Sunday Night Football cashing
out the longer a show stays on the air
the more contracts for all cast and crew
members have to be renegotiated and
re-signed and various union laws require
major pay raises for everyone involved
now sometimes it's worth the production
company and network's money The Big Bang
Theory for example has a main cast that
earns 1 million dollars per episode as
it enters its tenth season but that's
the exception to the rule generally the
longer a show as their ratings decline
just like CSI Miami that means a network
is paying more money for a show fewer
people watch and it's just my
cost-effective work toward a verdict is
in Frank
the jury is out cleaning the scene
speaking of being cost effective CBS has
a long history of keeping shows on the
air because it's cheap to make them in
pre-existing production facilities for
example in 1980 the Hawaii set of magnum
p.i made it to air in part because the
network could use the studios and crew
they had had in the area for the
production of the original Hawaii five-o
since the 1960s in 2012 CBS had a string
of new york-based cop shows in
production including CSI New York Blue
Bloods and NYC 22 and wanted to present
them all in a single three-hour block on
Friday nights with those shows all
produced in and around New York there
wasn't room in either the budget or the
schedule for a show shot in the far-off
expensive city of Miami or worse
stiff competition at the same time it
canceled CSI Miami CBS renewed the other
CSI spin-off on the air at the time CSI
New York and CSI Miami had better
overall ratings than its Gotham based
counterpart what gives
well CSI New York had helped turn a
little watch TV wasteland of Friday
nights into a big draw for CBS it
brought in fewer viewers than CSI Miami
but for Friday night it trailed only its
laid out
Blue Bloods in the ratings so CSI New
York lived because it was a big fish in
a smaller pond while CSI Miami got lost
in the shuffle
we have a victim that started the
weekend big man on campus and ended it
dead on arrival thanks for watching
subscribe to our YouTube channel to
watch more videos like the one you just
saw and leave us a comment to let us
know which CSI series was your favorite